and I hereby declare that Wendy Morton
has been duly elected
I would now like to invite the winning
candidate Wendy Morton to say a few
words please let me start by saying a
huge thank you first of all to the
presiding officer and to all of the many
many people who made this election
possible those who were up at the crack
of dawn to be at the polling station so
that they were ready for everyone to
come and vote to everyone who's been
here this evening as counting agents but
I'd also like to thank the police for
keeping us safe
throughout the campaign and today and
this evening also I would also like to
thank the members of my family who were
here this evening who day in day out
year after year have supported me in my
quest to become a member of parliament
and to remain a member of parliament I
couldn't do it without them I'd also
like to thank my agent and the many many
members of my team who have worked
tirelessly above and beyond what they
normally do to make sure that we were
here this evening and we returned a
fantastic result for the Conservatives
in Aldridge Brown Hills but none of this
would be possible without the democratic
system that we enjoy in this country and
the people across the constituency who
went out to vote today not just for me
but for all of the other candidates
standing alongside me here this evening
two years ago I was elected as a member
of parliament for Aldridge Brown Hills
for the first time I was not expecting
to be standing again just two years
later but that is politics I'd like to
thank everybody who voted for me when I
stood here two years ago
I pledged that I would do my best for
all of the constituents in aldrich brown
hills and I make that pledge again this
evening to you all
because it's not just Aldridge Brown
Hills the title of the constituency its
Aldridge its brown Hill its Streatley
it's Council it's Russell shell field
Hagi Walsall woods and the many
fantastic communities that make up my
constituency I promise you I will
continue to do my best to serve you all
in the forthcoming weeks months and
hopefully years ahead
thank you
[Applause]